our next paper is worth a billion
talking about capacity
well thank you for having invited me
here so so this talk will be we'll start
with describing the new royal model
which Christos correctly located
somewhere in antiquity so some of it is
old and then I'll describe more recent
things not since in this area kind of
the first decisions you make are often
the most important with describing at
length why one makes these early
decisions and starting maybe a bit
philosophically so one thing which is
self-evident in computer science which
hasn't quite penetrated neuroscience is
that certainly when you build artificial
systems they have to be interpreted at
many different levels and in the
engineering sense doesn't make it's not
credible that you build a system which
you only understand at just one level so
in neuroscience terms the main question
is you know what are the period of
operations which cortical computation
may take advantage of above this single
neuron level so the other concepts like
modularity rich and today's discuss and
and justified and biologists discussed
of course modularity can be justified on
the principle of of evolution the idea
of many levels
is easy to justify for engineering so
for biology biology it's less clear but
certainly if we didn't have many levels
of description and it would seem
hopeless to understand biology and in
particular the so the approach which I
take tries to exploit some quantitative
tension so what's it some problem which
you think about it does but it looks
completely intractable so how does it do
it so just as a as an example very
quickly the light bulb problem so this
is the idea you've got and light bulbs
maybe a 30 by 30 array of light bulbs
they each flash on and on on and off
independent if you look at one every
second it may be on and off according to
toss of a coin
and in fact all of them are independent
of each other except two are correlated
maybe 75% of the time they're correlated
so question is is this a cognitive
function which which biology can do okay
so lots of light bulbs independent
except for pair and question is to
define the pair so turns out that
computers computer scientists have
looked to this certain point is that
after about log n seconds
you've got enough information to decide
this question but computationally but
the problem is that so the obvious
method is to look at the pair of light
bulbs and see whether how similar they
are so this N squared is the obvious
algorithm and it's very hard to improve
on it there are improved algorithms into
the 1.58 but they look complicated so on
computational grants what we'll just do
one would conjecture that brain cannot
do it so in fact of course this
corresponds to a generic correlation
detection mechanism is the brain a
general correction detecting mechanism
and so I've never heard anyone suggest
that seriously and it this is consistent
with the computational theory that it
seems hopeless
ok so obviously certain correlations
like if every time you come to Berkeley
it rains you'll notice that because it's
a more important or if every time you
come to Berkeley the first person you be
coming out of bath has a red shirt
probably that collation you wouldn't
notice so the idea that we you know all
our thousands of concepts we can we go
around the deck correlations cognitively
no one suggested it and that's that's
consistent with computation so basically
my proposed methodology is similar but
now let's look at tasks which we do
believe called cognition does and maybe
those which I look difficult and see how
how the brain may do it this will give
us some some insight and the kind of
things which impressed me about the
brain symbolic processing green fox you
turn the green fork to the restaurant
yes I can handle that information and
determine it's a bad choice yes I can
deal with that was recommended by Joe I
heard the election result there so I can
deal with this kind of lots of law
of facts accumulated in my brain maybe
I'll even member tomorrow maybe in five
years time so this ability to treat
large amounts of cognitive information
is what impresses me so this is do
treating something so on scale so the
difficulty rule we always come from
treating things on scale where you deal
with large number of light bulbs large
number concepts okay
and also important to what I'll say is
this notion of chunking so the idea is
that these facts aren't believed to be
flat in our in our brains so we can make
a compound concept out of green and Fox
to restaurant becomes a high level
concept of an equal citizen below level
ones so chunking supernal and
psychological idea okay so so I'll
describe somebody basically decisions in
the New York model then I'll go on to
more recent things and I finish up with
I think my main purpose is to I find
quite exciting is that now for the first
time I think we're close to being being
able to test directly whether these kind
of competitions happen in the brain okay
so okay so the four primitives so so
main question is well it's not the right
light bulb problem what is the brain
doing and I think probably the choice of
your of what what your primitive tasks
are it's probably the main one or the
most important one and certainly
inductive learning as in deep learning
very important but actually my list okay
it's game number four which i think is
probably still the right decision so in
one sense inductive learning is it's too
easy I mean in as we found out you can
do a lot of interesting learning with
with simple learning mechanisms so that
won't give us this quantitative tension
and the other thing is that they're even
simpler things which which are hard to
do for the brain and so maybe just one
one comment is that I'm certainly
inductive learning is currently
practiced on massive scale millions of
examples most amount of computational
power
that's very powerful as far as
engineering for example because these
envision these lady mechanisms pick up
phenomena which probably picked up
through evolution which is engineering
they're very good but somehow the bigger
the scale you've practiced machine
learning on somehow the further it gets
from from neuroscience because we you
know that's not what we do okay so I'm
I'm telling you about the model I won't
give you a million examples and even
worse I wouldn't in in between my
examples I wouldn't retrain all the
examples of every other concept you've
learned in your life in the next 45
minutes okay so so the just in
interaction with the world in which
humans do as far as inductive learning
is just very different from what the
highest and machine learning thing is -
okay so inductive very important so
another one I'll call memorization of
conjunctions and this is basically
learning of an instance okay so if I
learn the word shakespeare that's an
instance and this discussion and it's a
different phenomenon okay so certainly
when you learn an instance there's some
noise tolerance so if I misspell some
letters I can correct it but it's kind
of the correction is probably something
accidental not particularly tuned to the
word solutes so this one stop learning
it's just a different phenomenon from
inductive learning so the people who try
to shoehorn birth into one and wonder
why deep networks content from one
example I think that's misplaced because
I think they're just two different tasks
there's one-shot learning memorization
and there's inductive learning when you
turn rise to different tasks okay let's
do so third task is Association again
that word is use many senses I'll define
this more more precisely but it's
basically when you have two concepts
which which you already know and you
train your mind so that whenever in the
future you think of X you think of Y so
we do that and then the fourth tasks is
some sense the most fundamental is how
you store a concept in the first place
you've got a new concept and your other
mobile where do you put it in your brain
for example okay so okay so these are
the four primitives
I have been looking at for a long time
and okay so that's the primitives and of
course these things only Pinterest if I
can do them at scale
okay so humans can't do tasks which
correspond to these formalizations you
know what in a thousands tens of
thousands in a life lifetime and the
miracle is that nearly once you did
haven't degraded that much okay so
that's the miracle we need to explain
sorry okay okay and and in a big thick
neuroscience books like with thousands
of pages but they don't tell you how
this is done they don't explain this
it's not that's not what they interested
okay so so the neural model the two
phases of it one is as a programming
language so your neurons as a directed
graph the communication is spikes now
each neuron executes a little algorithm
which is local to it which depends on
this package it receives and it may it
may emit a spike and these you kind of
program and so what the biological
correspondence is that it's known that
you know hundreds thousands of different
neurons which are really different they
expressed different genes genetically
different so why would you have hundreds
and or thousands of neurons if they
weren't
executing different algorithms I can't
think of why so the idea is that
evolution has has found has discovers
biochemical implementations of certain
little algorithms that need it fine okay
so looking for some universal model of
when you Iran is probably not the right
approach okay and so one design decision
which I remember struggling over is what
about synapses maybe synapses standards
maybe in the brain you know they're
biased Aniston after off the shelf but
again so all the attributes of the model
are introduced because I needed
something a programming latitude
and I needed to program synapses a bit
more than just having this weight and
also fortunately now there's known that
the synapses coming enormous variety
genetically etc so it's a this is a
cover programming model and the other
dimension moenay's programming in its
time so as we heard in Cruces is talking
also before so many things you have to
break symmetries a man bites dog dog
bites man how on earth do you do that
computation and somehow Africa symmetry
and the only method I found was was been
using timing so I think it brain needs
hardware assistant and programming
asymmetry in timing and so yeah and I
didn't think the spike time dependent
plasticity which came a few years
afterwards and of course the most
beautiful instance of it that if you
want whether you want to increase or
decrease ur a synaptic strength depends
on the relative timing of the two two
neurons so because you need a
programming language where you can
export Express all all these things and
also there's some weak same
synchronization probably riding on one
of these rhythms where basically the
idea is that you know if we sink we
start off some computation and we see a
scene and after step two three four I am
kind of I know what I'm doing is steps
two three or four I can rely on the
other neurons being also step two three
and four but the aim in the model is to
underestimate cortex so only put in
these mechanisms if you believe cortex
does its this purpose isn't to to
program some some something crazy okay
so I think evolution has managers to
make variations in the neural hardware
at it needs but what it is limited by
our to MIT resources so this is the
other aspect of the of the model that
they're strict numerical resources so
we're good in your arms if you want to W
on your runs you need a big your head
probably if you want to double the
number of connections you have so these
the number of connections to an
each neuron that's a very expensive
resource the third main resource our
deal with his synaptic strength so I've
got this number K and so K 20 means that
the maximum synaptic strength K 20 means
that you need K in your inspiring for
the person actually neuron to fire so K
equals MA means a single neuron can
cause a cascade but most neurons are
much weaker than that so K is much more
difficult to to measure and we don't
know that much about the distribution of
this case in cortex so these are all
parameters for me because we may be
dealing with a part of of cortex and
some of the numbers may not be known so
the fourth parameter is time not much
negotiate over time but the mechanisms
are use are all two or three steps so
you have to be very economical in time
because your brain is slow okay and why
all this works is that the details of
what you programmed in neurons don't
seem to be the most important thing the
brain sir communication challenged
sparse connection slow spikes that
somehow that's where you can get the
quantitative tension okay so so just a
slightly more detail as far as the these
tasks so each of these tasks has a
definition so okay so first time you
heard of Donald Trump must must be in
such a moment so so how did you what
happened in your brain did you allocate
storage about so in this definition you
know you did do an operation which is to
allocate storage to this concept and the
definition here is in the manner of
chunking in psychology that you believe
that parts of this concept you already
knew
so maybe Donald is some concept in you
and Trump you already knew and the
action you did was to allocate some more
neurons to this task to this concept
which cost which will correspond to
Donald Trump and
future okay so you so you're born with
this random graph in some state and each
experience you have you update some
weights basically and maybe some states
so you're on sub States as well
okay so you that storage allocation and
this is chunky so that's that's one
operation and again we've got the
circuit and interaction with the world
will modify the circuit so the circuit
behaves differently yes okay so so so
the one assumption here is that I have a
set of neurons cross-linked to Donald
okay so I'll say more about that and say
particular the experiments which are
familiar to all of you where people poke
electrodes into certain parts of the
brain and find your runs which
correspond to two concepts like like
Bill Clinton and for example you can in
these experiments you find that maybe
one in five hundred of neurons in that
part of your brain are very big in turn
asked in a certain sense so these are
complicated but but the idea that
there's this locality that certain
neurons really correspond to consummate
certain you know s do not have some
foundation and this is the assumption of
the model so okay so an item here
corresponds to set up your own set of
our neurons we don't know what our is
and then you have to make a decision
whether the Bill Clinton neurons are
they destroying from all the other
concepts or are they shared without the
concept so you can have two different
represent representations and and
algorithms so this item is very similar
to crew sessions assemblies but exactly
as he says
traditionally in assemblies there's some
notion that what represents the concepts
concept is somehow richly connected and
here I don't have that assumption and so
we can discuss
afterwards whether that assumption
whether this strong connectivity helps
you or hinders you okay so I think it it
hinders you I think you can do a lot
without this assumption we can defer
that discussion okay okay so so that was
one one operation so the second
operation is Association which will mean
that
now we're not allocating new neurons you
already have two concepts in your brain
Donald Trump like the president the
concepts you understand and then you
need some protocol by which if you
stimulate these two concepts a and B in
some way
the result was will be that in the
future when you think of Donald Trump
you know he's been elected president
okay so this is very similar to nurse of
heterogeneity learning which goes back
to the 60s the Association got real
Association is using many different
senses so here I've got definitions of
each of these okay so these are
operations and so I the second I'll tell
you what the outcomes look like but what
the goal is I want to demonstrate that
there's some way in which you imagine
the brain does this okay so a bit like
the lights but for the light bulb
problem and I know no if no
implementation for these which are more
more cognitive I struggled to find
something okay so I think what we do is
that you know we're told in association
there maybe you're given an example of
an elephant so you so you find your
national elephants
that's inductive learning supervised
memorization is it's a bit like a
definite one-shot learning bit like a
definition I tell you what a group is in
mathematics and then hierarchical
memorization is advocating a new concept
so we seem to be able to do these
operations succession and again the
miracle is that it doesn't degrade as
much in the show okay it does degrade
okay so how so how can you explain this
so using outcomes I'm quite described
yet and this is a setting in which
things are pretty complicated it's hard
to analyze but you can do simulations
which is done with Vitaly Feldman some
years ago the question is what's the
capacity how many of these tasks can you
do before your performance degrades the
grades means that the early things
you've learned have are gone or confused
okay so it's not that easy to do so
again we got these four parameters
number of neurons certain t8 some part
of your brain 8,000 connections per
neuron that's reasonable K equals 16 is
some sort of synaptic strength and then
so we've got always enormous by the
third of a million but roughly it's
corresponds to these experiments with
Bill Clinton cells that it's like why
100 five hundredths of part of your
brain so all could be enormous or could
be small different parts of brain could
have different ours I don't know what
the R is and also I don't know what the
case should be either different parts of
the brain may use different case but if
you just try it off the results a bit
disappointing you get about 3,000
actions before things degrade and again
I don't quite know what what what's good
for human performance what's a expert
humans performance so the Oxford English
Dictionary has half a million words but
most people don't know that you know all
that Shakespeare have used 30,000 words
and it was quite successful there's
enough for him so so probably there's
something in the hundreds of thousands
maybe a reasonable aim for for these
tasks okay now you can't get more
realistic more numbers you're proud of
like we've got about a quarter million
successful actions if we use strong
synapses maximally strong synapses so
these are synapses which are so strong
but a single neuron can cause us a curse
it's occurs in neuron to fire and you
know whether
cortex uses these whether primate cortex
human cortex uses these this kind of
open maybe even
has discovered this maybe not but
algorithmically strong synapses are very
good I suppose intuitively you know gets
more boolean okay so if we do
computations yes okay but these strong
synapses is an assumption but otherwise
everything we do is I think it's
plausible okay and so so that's one of
these tasks I have analyzed it's quite
seriously I mean it's enough to do
simulations for many purposes one
there's more detailed analysis for this
is associations so that's very briefly
I'll describe that and and again I'll
just spell out why this is not exactly
what people usually mean my association
ok so here it is a one-shot learning
every association you hear once
it's kind of lifelong learning in the
sense that you get one to hear lots of
things like 10 10 10 to the 5 tasks you
you each here once so learning doesn't
just mean that you're learning the
information so sit somewhere passively
but learning means that you finish up
with a circuit which does something so
if you hear Donald you may think of
Donald Trump also the sub circuits are
will be composable which means that if
you hear that someone's been coming like
the president and you ready to know what
presidents do then in a flash your
cortex can follow through the
implication and this has some
constraints on the algorithm simply
means that the inputs and the output
sciences of the neurons after me the
same okay and so the whole architecture
has to be plausible so this would be a
random graph for my connections and
there maybe the main point is that
although I'm analyzing one task the
whole point is that it should be in a
context where you can implement other
useful tasks ok so just being very good
at one tasking I think is the wrong
approach you have to be able to do a set
of tasks which you think between them
it's useful like allocating storage
Association
some inductive learning etc okay so so
just to emphasize this okay so what the
outcome consists of is it's very simple
so the two simple algorithms which are
compare so the simplest implementation
is that because this random graph set a
of neurons represents Donald Trump a set
C of neurons represents elected
president and these already allocated
and when you learn the the Association
some weights get changed so that in the
future when you stimulate the Donald
Trump neurons then you will stimulate
the electric president neurons and don't
do too much other damage so there lots
of negative constraints that you don't
want to do spurious things and this is
compared with a more elaborate algorithm
so so advantage of this algorithm is
that basically a almost a random bunch
of neurons does this so it is
evolutionarily this is the default so
this is more advanced so we got a not a
layer but like half your neurons do no
learning this but they've got fixed
fixed very high weights and the
communication between the a and the C
are through these neurons so in some
sense these are some sort of amplifiers
so it's connected to the neurons in this
relay neurons each of these discussions
to do more so you get much more fan-out
okay so that seems a obviously good idea
but the problem is that you're much more
likely to to confuse things because in
this regime we are going to represent
every concept by set of neurons and
these news are going to overlap okay so
the lot of scope for for error and so a
bit more formally
so maybe x1 could be Donald Trump y1 is
Elektra Elektra president and then we
got see other associations associations
you've learned
okay so the question is how how many can
you learn without degradation and the
number of neurons use for your concepts
should be the same if you want to
compose these and cut the main most
obvious question is whether there is an
information theoretic limit roughly T
times n so you end your runs in your
brain the snap says into each just DN
synapses so kind of the best you can
hope for is that you can the capacity is
you can have one memory or one
Association person apps okay so can that
be achieved or in in other words so if
you take a conventional if the number of
connections is the square root of number
of neurons you've already heard about
questions can you memorize number of
correlations which grow faster than n
okay those grows faster the number of
neurons as fast as the number of
synapses and there's also some semantics
what do I mean by Bill Clinton cells so
here this is rather extremely uptight
semantics which says that all of my
neurons will fire I only say that myself
neurons rippln representing Bill
Clinton's all no firing and then we are
doing Association I want all except
possibly one to fire so it's a very
strict criterion which in real life you
I'm sure you can do with things which
are much less strict okay so anyway so
this summary is that with this the
simplest algorithm random bunch of
neurons the capacity in this regime only
grows as d squared which will be path
proportional to the number of neurons if
the square root of n reverse with the
most elaborate one you can reach
information capacity and so the
intuition mathematically is that these
concepts are these lost sets lost sets
of neurons which
app lot of room for confusion so when
you're lots of neurons a expanse to your
intermediate neurons it expands even
more the overlaps will get even bigger
and it'll get even easier to to confuse
things okay so by having this so before
yeah just kind of reach from each you
you could reach the other and I can
reach t-squares
sounds great but but also the scope for
making making spurious firings become
girl grows so this turns out to be a
finely balanced phenomenon in in random
graphs and it turns out that strong
synapses are computationally would be
very useful okay so okay so that's one
possible way of explaining human
performance so there's also an another
way of how we can reach more convincing
capacities so it turns out that I had
these four basic primitives and one of
the weak points was that the mechanism I
used allocating storage for new concept
Donald Trump the mechanism I used
between cortex has a high variance so if
I want to allocate the million neurons
it's kind of maybe I'll get a million
and a half sometimes alpha million other
times so you pay a high cost for that so
it seems that for that primitive of
allocating source for something new
controlling how many neurons the
alligator's is pretty important and it
turns out that a simple feed-forward
network with the right parameters is
able to stabilize the number of neurons
allocated so this is like suggesting a
separate mechanism we should put on top
of cortex to help you do one of the
tasks it's not done within cortex using
another gadget improves things okay but
this task which you could do better is
in fact this chunking task okay the
psychological chunking and now when we
do chunking allocate a new memory what
do you think of well
is the hippocampus the hippocampus is
the part of your brain which is
necessary for allocating new storage
exactly very similar sense to how I'm
discussing it so so the obvious
hypothesis if you want I risky
hypothesis but is that in the brain is
the hippocampus which does this so the
theory is that
well the hippocampus does is the most
basic for the thing you decide where you
put something new so if you want to want
to memorize a new concept and there's
some locality the first problem is when
you put it you can't just that's it for
you okay so that's the UM but it may do
other things as well so besides just so
it would be like a hash function it it
identifies the neurons you want to store
it at but obviously it also helps to
helps it to to get there so hippocampus
isn't just a simple feet forward thing
okay so this is kind of where the theory
is so quickly as far as experimental
validation well there are some very
simple things which I one can say so
let's say telltale predictions so you
got a theory
it's requires some things maybe you find
it late in experiments so strong
synapses certainly when I first worked
on this it's obvious that strong
synapses were useful computationally
neuroscientists gave me no help in in
enabling in permitting me to think they
were they were they existed
so even synapses or a few millivolts
they hadn't been observed okay so anyway
so and another kind of prediction you
can make is that it once you've got an
algorithm then you you do have a
connection between these parameters and
it's number of neurons D is the number
of connections case the synaptic
strength our summary neurons used for a
for a concept so in some simple systems
these things are measurable so so G
Laura has a paper about ten years ago
for the olfactory system of the locust
where for example are is you give the
locust natural odor and R is how many
neurons or
excited by it also you can measure the
synaptic strength so for particular
systems you can see whether these
numbers fit and for historic experiments
these things fit quite well but I think
what's possible now it's a much much
more direct validation of whether the
particular systems are more primitives
I'm suggesting our or in fact what the
brain is at least capable of so ok so
the method would be this is old
old-fashioned words in actually
engineering in circuit testing so if you
go to circuit you can test this by give
me the inputs outputs whatever another
way is to put electricity and then
seeing whether little parts that's what
you think it does so why not do it in in
the brain surprisingly neuroscientist
don't like you too much because they
like natural stimuli but we natural
stimuli because so much going on that
you don't not testing what you want
tested ok so this would be the
simplistic experiment so the so if these
associations are described if the brain
does them then this experiment should
work so the experiment would be that
what you have to look in the right parts
of the brain which are the part of your
brain does this so the theory is that
you take a random set of a neurons
another random set of being neurons and
that you stimulate them at conscious and
protocol doesn't exactly what but the
results will be that in the future when
you just stimulate a then B will become
active and not much else you don't want
too much noise ok so so this would be a
verification that this primitive is
being implemented what is any of my
particular algorithms it wouldn't verify
that but the primitive is more important
they functionality where they
associations like this implement and
it's kind of the important thing and
exactly which out rhythm is almost
second-order so the difficulties here
are that you have to say for being
Euron's they can randomly test random is
selected and in the training you have to
stimulate it
and then in recording you have to the
record from it to from the same set of
neurons you have to train and record
from so that's becoming possible so the
other difficulty is that we don't quite
know what what are should be should you
do to shoot on a hundred neurons each a
thousand euros each and depending on it
on this number you use different
techniques and there may be different
different difficulties but there's no
reason why you know we can't find this
kind of thing out okay so okay okay
again the question is whether cortex
this will test where the cortex has the
capability of of doing this this kind of
in this kind of Association I think
that's okay um and as far as other
things
okay so obstacle of the optogenetics
that's how you do this the other sources
of experimentation which will shed light
on this kind of theory so connectomics
I think the main problem so that's from
this perspective is that we'd find out
how strong synapses are so strong
synapses are tend to be big as you say
they're strong synapses or I care about
is the connection between two neurons is
how strong the influences of one on on
another whether it's many small synapses
or one huge one I don't care is the net
total synaptic strength from one you're
on and kind of experiments would be so
if you've got some imaging some
recording mechanism vertical good timing
you can make fine time distinctions then
maybe you can also get results which
reminiscent of the night of the natural
language things about basic mechanisms
of how how your brain resolves the time
dimension exactly how you process man
buys dog versus dog right man so there
are several avenues where one can do a
better can expect future experiments can
resolve yeah so I should have said that
all so what I'm doing here I think I'm
looking at attracting things which are
constant quantities very difficult to
explain but to make a brain work this
would be in conjunction with some
working memory apparatus as well so
you're saying if someone asks me a
question are these two things similar
what do I do
so I think if you ask me any question I
am i working memory I are bringing some
information from our long-term M which
is relevant and kind of taught toy
around with it so so presumably the
answer question depends on some previous
knowledge of the domain of know if you
ask me whether if you showed me two
pictures of dinosaurs are they similar
or not depends on my expertise of
dinosaurs well then I'll say yes or no
right so so I think we bring in
information of this nature that they
could be generalizations that could be
one-shot learning or there could be
associations or somehow you know
whatever question you ask me I'll bring
in the relevant information which I've
learned from with these rules and turn
them over
well I'd argue that probably you need at
least these four okay so I sent question
is how much can you build on top of
these so question is maybe the
computational sense you know if you have
these four at one level yeah can you
build the computations as everything
else on top of it
maybe answer's no maybe you want to v 1
or a 6 1 but I want to keep that level
limited okay so I don't know so in the
title so that referred to particularly
these associations the idea is that if I
learn associations then my my brain
which can you give me Donald Trump then
after associations but what is his
position is what people inspiration can
do ok so I can compose associations on
the fly without reflection ok so it
means that there's some the way you set
up the circuits it's not just you put
these circuits randomly in your brain
you have to put them in your brain so
they are composable ok so if these
circuits are in your brain so if you
deduce that someone's president you meet
we have to use everything about
presidents process
you just assumed chunks the blocks but
how do you really think the blocks in a
sequence for example no it does because
you you represents a notional president
myself neurons and then these you're
gonna fire by some piece of information
and then these will be enough to fire
the next Association flexible way well
it's all it's all do it in some in some
fixed way you know that if you want to
do anything more complicated and you
probably have to bring it into your
working memory and think about it but
you'd think you do want some minimal
capability in which the circuit can you
know you learn association so you can
compress them on the fly in your circuit
okay so this will be done on the fly
early on and it just seems like if you
if you adopted that in your
representation then you would be able to
get access to the facts about a
president and in it in a sort of logical
way rather than I do I don't know how
we're gonna read these out it just seems
like we could just flip them out but
linearly it seems it instinct in your
formulism but you really want something
that has a meta structure that you can
access the association's in there in a
more useful way well I think if you if
you do any explicit reason reasoning on
it then I think you have to throw it
into your working memory and that's
where you figure out if you want to do
some move something you want to reach a
new conclusion for the first time you'll
you'll some new reasoning for first time
you'll do that in your working memory
where you but I think questions how much
can you do in your circuit without your
working memory
automatically and I'm saying you can do
quite a bit and I think you do need some
capability of being able to do so to
string associations two together without
rift without
okay so okay so so in this definition
with each thing you had won a single
Association in more complex situations
if you have a conjunction of things of
several that in a context you'd reach a
different conclusion yes yes so this is
if you like it's reflux yes seeing how
much accomplished how you can learn
complicated reflexes in your cortex
pattern would cause of pattern being
that this would be learned I mean that's
it that's a that's an idea that you know
has been I would have been called an
axiom rather than a prediction I mean a
visual image that causes an auditory
pattern the name of the object so I'm
trying to see what I mean maybe William
James might have said that back in 1898
and had said that so I would have said
that something that is that is
universally accepted as a primitive in
the brain is the ability to learn an
association between a and B by changing
synapses between neurons so is am I
missing something when you propose that
you're proposing an experiment to test
whether this is really true yes okay so
the main thing I'm saying is that
looking at a single primitive one at a
time isn't very fruitful you have to
look at the set of primitives which I
said contragravity our advocate adequate
like I've got these four so I want to
show that all these four together
realizable and so yes so if someone
shows it's an experiment then next thing
is whether you can do the other
experiments I want to show in the same
way that the other primitives are
implementable okay so I think it's one
primitive by itself doesn't give you
very much okay as you say further on
will.shaw studied neural
exactly in this association since I did
and and people did before so what
becomes quantitatively difficult is if
you want to do several different things
at the same time storage allocation
concept so it seemed like it suggests
that initially there would be empty
space which would be filled with
something that is allocated or there
would be the bottom of the hierarchy the
most basic object primitives which every
other eventually represent objects is
built up from this associative manner so
you're born with some sensory devices
and probably outputs of the sensory
devices maybe a single and you're on
your retina could be a bit primitive
such a theory is that so I'm sure that
evolution is given that built things on
top of it already
but so you're born with something with
some things so if something happens to
you some some set of neurons light up
some assemblies okay and you build on
top of this you're born with some and
you've done
[Applause]